dans un instant nous allons faire un
très très très long voyage pour
retrouver en direct de l'espace la
première spationaute française claudie
andré des qui a passé sa neuvième
journée à bord de la station orbitale
mir avant de retrouver la terre ferme
lundi prochain avant ce duplex spatiale
un rapide rappel de cette mission en
compagnie de jean-claude allanic elle
tourne à près de 400 km au dessus de nos
têtes et toutes les 90 minutes claudie
andré deshaies peut apercevoir l'europe
à travers les hublots de mire et c'est
ici dans la partie centrale de la
station orbitale que la française
retrouve ses compagnons de voyage les
quatre russes et l'américaine shannon
lucide
par exemple pour déguster les derniers
produits frais amener de la terre une
fête surtout pour l'équipage russe qui
est l'eau depuis le 8 février
la mission de la française elle
s'achèvera lundi prochain il lui faut
donc mettre les bouchées doubles pour
mener à bien un programme scientifique
très chargé tests médicaux pour étudier
la circulation du sang et le
comportement du coeur en état
d'apesanteur expérience de physique pour
mesurer les déformations des structures
métalliques dans l'espace
et puis il ya aussi l'expérience fertile
mené sur six femelles salamandre mais
salamandre qui au début ont donné des
sueurs froides aux responsables du
programme en refusant de pondre plutôt
ennuyeux quand il s'agit d'observer le
développement des e et la division des
cellules sans la gravité terrestre
mais aux dernières nouvelles les
femelles récalcitrantes ce serait
rattrapé en pondant près de 700 e
finalement beaucoup plus que prévu voilà
en direct de l'espace nous allons
trouver
claudie envoie dès les premières
spationaute française en compagnie de
jean-claude allanic bonsoir est-ce que
vous m'entendez est ce que vous pouvez
me préciser quels pays où quel continent
vous survolez actuellement
le sud de l'australie
est ce qu'on peut avoir des nouvelles de
vos salamandre femelle qui ont un peu
tardé à pondre par un an
jean chazal et jean falala il est encore
question le ministre a déclaré que des
missions de 14 jours c'était trop court
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour des
missions plus longues
et à fait favorable à des missions
beaucoup plus longue parce qu'on
pourrait faire davantage de choses alors
la liaison sont vraiment un petit peu
difficile et nous sommes vraiment en
direct vous pouvez nous rappeler à
combien de kilomètres se traite à deux
nuits à peu près 400 km au dessus ça
fait quand même pas mal de de distancer
la difficulté c'est que nature dans la
station orbitale se déplace et on a de
la peine à voir à la fois l'image et le
son est une toute dernière question que
le dis on va dès samedi soir c'était
soirée de gala à bord avec un repas
gastronomique préparé par le lycée
hôtelier de souillac avec entre autres
des menus de caillots madère alors toute
dernière question est ce que vous êtes
libre ce soir et est ce que vous soyez
d'accord pour sortir avec moi
on lui souhaite un très très bon appétit
apparemment tout va bien bourg merci
infiniment d'avoir été en direct avec
nous donc à 400 kilomètres au dessus du
plancher des vaches au revoir et bonne
continuation donc en principe rentrer
sur terre lundi soir c'est ça nous
allons terminer ce journal en compagnie
d'une autre femme qui elle aussi fait
beaucoup parler d'elle mais dans un tout
autre registre je parlais de la
comédienne américaine sharon stone dans
son tout dernier film last dance ou
dernière danse si vous préférez qui sort
demain sur nos écrans